IN THE U.K.
BACK TO YOU.
AINSLEY: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET’S BRING IN DR. MARC SIEGEL
FOX NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR.
DR. SIEGEL, I KNOW YOU HAVE SAID
THAT THIS IS VERY CONCERNING.
HE IS 55 YEARS OLD, BORIS
JOHNSON WHY ARE YOU SO
CONCERNED?
HE IS NOT ON THE VENTILATOR YET.
>> AINSLEY, WHY I’M NOT
CONCERNED IS BECAUSE HE IS 55
AND HE IS IN GOOD HEALTH AS FAR
AS WE KNOW.
NO UNDERLYING MEDICAL CONDITIONS
AND EXERCISES A LOT.
HE IS KNOWN AS AN EXERCISE
PERSON.
ALL OF THAT IS GOOD WHAT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT IS 10 DAYS AFTER
HE FIRST STARTED HAVING THIS HE
IS STILL HAVING THE PERSISTENT
FEVER, THE COUGH AND THE
SHORTNESS OF BREATH.
THE SHORTNESS OF BREATH
REQUIRING OXYGEN IMPLIES THERE
IS LUNG INVOLVEMENT GOING ON
HERE.
IT’S REALLY GOOD NEWS THAT HE IS
NOT ON THE VENTILATOR AT THIS
POINT.
WE ALSO LOOK AT THE HEART, THE
KIDNEY, THE LIVER.
WE LOOK AT ALL OF THE ORGANS IN
THIS KIND OF A SITUATION.
ESPECIALLY THE INFLAMMATION IN
THE LUNGS.
OUR HOPES AND PRAYERS ARE WITH
HIM THE FACT THAT HE HASN’T
GOTTEN WORSE SINCE HE HAS GOTTEN
INTO THE ICU PER YOUR LAST
REPORT COULD HAVE SOMETHING TO
DO THAT THE ICU INTENSIVE CARE
UNIT IS BEING USED AS A
PRECAUTION.
MAY BE A WAY OF GIVING HIM
CLOSER AND CLOSER OBSERVATION.
IF WE MAKE SURE AND WE SEE THAT
HE IS NOT ON THE VENTILATOR,
THAT’S GOING TO BE A GOOD SIGN.
BRIAN: YEAH, WE WILL SEE.
THAT’S GOT PEOPLE CONCERNED.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT, TOO THE
FACT THAT THE QUEEN CAME OUT AND
MADE A SPEECH WHICH SHE ALMOST
DIDN’T MAKE.
NEVER MAKES BEFORE VERY RARELY
IN HOLIDAY THEY THOUGHT SHE
MIGHT HAVE KNOWN SOMETHING.
WE WILL SEE WHERE THAT GOES.
LET’S TALK ABOUT WHAT GOVERNOR
CUOMO WAS SAYING YESTERDAY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
BRIAN: GOVERNOR CUOMO TALKING
ABOUT LESS INCUBATION AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND LESS PEOPLE
GOING INTO ICUs.
CURVE IS PENDING.
BACK OF MY MIND I KEEP HEARING
SURGEON GENERAL SAYING THIS WEEK
IS PEARL HARBOR AND 9/11.
WHAT AM TOY BELIEVE?
>> BRIAN, YOU SHOULD BELIEVE
BOTH.
WE ARE STILL NOT OUT OF THE
WOODS YET AND WE ARE SEEING AS
YOU KNOW OVER 100,000 CASES IN
NEW YORK ALONE.
AND WITH THE DEATH RATE STARTING
TO FLATTEN OUT, THAT’S A VERY
GOOD SIGN.
BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN GET DIAGNOSED
AND THEN LATER ON GET SERIOUS
FLICTIONs.
I THINK ALL OF THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
THE SHELTER IN PLACE.
ALL OF THE PRECAUTIONS WE ARE
TAKING ARE DEFINITELY HELPING
DRAMATICALLY.
I THINK THAT’S VERY GOOD NEWS.
THE OTHER ISSUE IS CAN WE GET
MORE RAPID TESTING?
THAT’S ANOTHER THING.
AINSLEY MENTIONED AT THE TOP
THAT AT NYU LANGONE, MY HOSPITAL
WE ARE STUDYING SOME TREATMENT,
SOME TO DECREASE INFLAMMATION IN
THE LUNGS.
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IS BEING
STUDIED EARLY IN THE GAME.
THESE TREATMENTS CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE POTENTIALLY.
SOCIAL DISTANCING HUGE.
AND CAN WE FIGURE OUT WHO HAS
THIS RAPIDLY AND SEPARATE THEM
OUT?
I DEFINITELY THINK IN NEW YORK
WE ARE HEADING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AS OTHER HOT SPOTS ARE EMERGING
LIKE IN LOUISIANA AND FLORIDA.
NEW YORK, DEFINITELY APPEARS TO
BE TURNING THE CORNER, SLOWLY.
STEVE: AND YOU KNOW, DR. SIEGEL,
IT WAS TWO DAYS AGO THAT
DR. BIRX SAID FROM THE PODIUM
SHE SAID, YOU KNOW, DON’T GO TO
THE GROCERY STORE.
DON’T GO TO THE PHARMACY.
AND YESTERDAY SHE ACTUALLY
CLARIFIED AND SHE SAID SHE MEANT
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF TRIPS,
CONSOLIDATE.
ONLY SEND ONE PERSON FROM YOUR
FAMILY AND TRY TO ONLY GO ONCE
EVERY TWO WEEKS IF THAT IS AT
ALL POSSIBLE.
THAT’S REALLY GOOD ADVICE IF YOU
CAN WAIT TWO WEEKS.
>> YEAH.
STEVE.
PEOPLE CAN’T REALLY WAIT TWO
WEEKS.
I THINK THE MAJOR ISSUE HERE IS
TO BE CONSCIOUS OF THINGS.
TO BE CONSCIOUS OF YOU WHO CLOSE
YOU ARE TO PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, I THINK PEOPLE OUT
THERE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
WITH ALL OF THE ASYMPTOMATIC
SPREAD, PEOPLE THAT HAVE THIS
AND DON’T KNOW ABOUT IT, THAT’S
WHY WE’RE ADDING ADDITIONAL
PRECAUTIONS LIKE WEARING A MASK
WHEN YOU ARE CLOSE TO PEOPLE
BECAUSE YOU MIGHT HAVE IT AND
NOT KNOW IT.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO BE CONSCIOUS
OF THAT.
IT’S NOT ABOUT HOW OFTEN YOU GO
TO THE GROCERY STORE.
IT’S WHAT YOU DO WHEN YOU GET
THERE.
ARE YOU BEING CAREFUL?
ARE YOU, AGAIN, GOING HOME AND
WASHING EVERYTHING?
WASHING YOUR HANDS?
ARE YOU AWARE OF WHO IS NEXT TO
YOU, WHAT THEY ARE DOING?
IT’S ABOUT STAYING AWARE.
AINSLEY: DR. SIEGEL I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED NYU LANGONE MEDICAL
SCHOOL WHERE YOU PREACH OR
PRACTICE OUGHT THAT HOSPITAL.
LANGONE HAS BEEN ON OUR STORY A
BUNCH.
HIS STORY CAME FROM NOTHING AND
CREATED THIS EMPIRE GIVING SO
MUCH MONEY TO-TO-THAT HOSPITAL.
BILL AND MELINDA GATES ARE
FUNDING THAT HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE
TRIAL.
THEY ARE SPENDING BILLIONS TO
COME UP WITH FACILITIES, 7
FACILITIES TO TRY TO FIND THIS
VACCINE.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY COMING
TOGETHER AND PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MADE A LOT OF MONEY ARE GIVING
BACK TO THIS COUNTRY AND IT’S
JUST AWESOME TO WITNESS THAT.
THIS IS EMAIL FROM TIMOTHY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AINSLEY: YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON
THAT?
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
KNOW KEN LANGONE HAS A
TREMENDOUS HEART.
A GRATE ENTREPRENEUR.
AND HE IS THE RIGHT SPIRIT OF
THE COUNTRY AT THIS TIME.
AND BILL AND MELINDA GATES AS
WELL.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
A TIME OF ENTREPRENEURSHIP, A
TIME GIVING BACK, IT’S THE
AMERICAN SPIRIT.
AINSLEY: ABSOLUTELY.
LET ME GET BACK TO THAT EMAIL
FROM TIMOTHY.
HE SAYS MY DAUGHTER IS A
HEALTHCARE WORKER SHE AND HER
7-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER LIVE WITH
US.
SHOWFD WE QUARANTINE HER IN HER
ROOM WHEN SHE GETS HOME FROM
WORK.
SHOULD WE QUARANTINE HER FROM
HER DAUGHTER.
>> FANTASTIC QUESTION.
I’M MORE INTERESTED IN STAYING
AWAY FROM YOU, THE WRITER OF THE
EMAIL.
BECAUSE YOU ARE OLDER.
AS FAR AS WE KNOW, AND THIS
APPLIES TO YOUR LOVELY DAUGHTER,
AINSLEY.
YOUNGER CHILDREN ARE NOT
GETTING.
THIS IF THEY’RE, THEY ARE
GETTING MUCH MILDER CASES.
A HEALTHCARE WORKER SHOULD BE
CHANGING CLOTHES CONSTANTLY.
SEMI QUARANTINING.
TAKING A SHOWER WHEN THEY GET
HOME.
AND THEY SHOULD BE GETTING
TESTED FREQUENTLY.
THAT’S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
WE ARE TESTING OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKERS NOW.
SO WE CAN SEE IF THEY HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO COVID-19.
THEY SHOULDN’T BE FULLY
QUARANTINED.
THEY SHOULD STAY AS SEPARATE AS
POSSIBLE.
BRIAN: YEAH, SO FARTHER STANDARD
TEST STILL TAKES SEVEN DAYS TO
GET BACK.
I CAN’T WAIT TO GET THAT
15-MINUTE TEST AND THAT’S
EVERYWHERE.
I DON’T KNOW HOW LONG THAT’S
GOING TO BE.
>> THAT’S EMERGING NOW.
BRIAN: I HOPE SO.
IT SAYS THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
BACK AND FORTH ABOUT WEARING
MASKS.
WHAT DO WE DO TO PROTECT OUR
EYES?
GOGGLES?
>> BRIAN, THERE WAS A NEW STUDY
OUT YESTERDAY THAT EMPHASIZED
THAT THE MASKS CAN BE FAULTY AND
YOU HAVE TO WEAR THEM IN JUST
THE RIGHT WAY AND THE CLOSER TO
A SURGICAL MASK THE BETTER AND
THAT KEEPS FROM YOU SPREADING IT
TO OTHERS.
NOT -- WE’RE NOT WORRIED ABOUT
OTHER PEOPLE SPREADING IT TO
YOU.
WORRIED ABOUT YOU COULD HAVE IT
AND NOT SPREADING IT.
AS FAR AS EYES ARE CONCERNED,
THE PROBLEM, BRIAN, WE ARE
ALWAYS PUTTING OUR FINGERS IN
THE EYES.
THAT’S PROBABLY THE NUMBER ONE
BUY WE SPREAD.
THIS I WANT PEOPLE TO BE MORE
CONSCIOUS OF THAT RUBBING THEIR
EYES.
I WANT TO ADD SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE NEVER SAID.
SOMETHING VERY SIMPLE.
WHEN YOU WASH YOUR HANDS, WASH
YOUR FACE.
WE ALWAYS SAY WASH YOUR HANDS.
WASH YOUR FACE.
BECAUSE VIRUSES LIVE ON YOUR
FACE.
AND YOU ARE ALWAYS TOUCHING YOUR
SO, BE AWARE OF THAT.
WASH YOUR HANDS, AND WASH YOUR
FACE.
STEVE: HANDS FIRST, GOTCHA.
MEANWHILE, DOCTOR, EMAIL FROM
CATHY SHE WRITES:  SOCIAL
DISTANCING SEEMS TO BE WORKING
BUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE GET OUT
AND ABOUT AGAIN, WON’T THE VIRUS
SPREAD ONCE AGAIN?
AND THAT’S THE WORRY.
YOU KNOW, WHEN PEOPLE SEE THAT
THE -- YOU KNOW WE ARE ON THE
BACK SIDE OF THE APEX,
DR. SIEGEL THEY WILL GO OKAY, WE
ARE BACK TO NORMAL.
NOT GOING TO WORK LIKE THAT, IS
IT?
>> I HAVE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
ANSWER THAN A MENTOR OF MINE
DR. TONY FAUCI ON THIS WHO SAYS
WE HAVE TO KEEP THE SAME DEGREES
SOCIAL DISTANCING IN PLACE UNTIL
WE GET A VACCINE.
AND I WILL TELL YOU WHAT MY
THOUGHTS ARE A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
I THINK THE VACCINE IS GOING TO
BE THE LANDMARK THAT WE NEED.
BUT, IN THE MEANTIME, WE ARE
LEARNING GOOD HABITS NOW.
HABITS THAT WE SHOULD TAKE
FORWARD.
BUT I REALLY WANT YOU TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IF WE KNOW WHO
HAS THIS VIRUS, WHO IS IMMUNE TO
THIS VIRUS, WHO CAN GO BACK TO
WORK, WHO IS STILL SICK, THAT’S
GOING TO BE ABLE TO HELP US
DECREASE THE AMOUNT THAT WE ARE
USING THE DRACONIAN MEASURES.
BECAUSE IF WE KNOW YOU ARE
IMMUNE, YOU ARE PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET IT
AGAIN.
IF WE KNEW YOU HAVE IT.
SOCIAL DISTANCING IS NOT ENOUGH.
YOU HAVE GOT TO BE QUARANTINED.
THAT’S WHY I KEEP HARPING ON THE
RAPID TESTING.
SO I THINK WE CAN DECREASE THE
AMOUNT OF DRACONIAN MEASURES THE
MORE WE KNOW WHO HAS IT AND WHO
IS IMMUNE.